welcome back to singfield cup I'm here
with lard Domingos the game finished in
a draw the third game already of round 8
is over um what happened today I think
it was also preparation from your
opponent which yeah I was a bit
surprised by this line it's not very
common and um yeah he seemed extremely
well well prepared I think um I more or
less remember that this was possible but
uh yeah after um we went for this whole
line with it takes F5
E4 F6 Knight F5 already I was uh kind of
trying to to find out what to do um so
F3 it's a very forcing move yeah um I
was considering Knight D4 but um it was
clear that after something like takes
takes and queen F6 black should be fine
uh there's also Queen A5 check on top of
this I got the CD also Queen A5 for in
white to move the king and it doesn't
look very good like after King F1 maybe
long Castle or something like that so um
I had to play F3 uh Queen
F6 and yeah um I guess F4 was possible
Queen H4
G3 Knight takes C3 Queen F2 and D takes
C4 uh probably this is what he has
prepared look to draw which to me
probably is Bishop B5 check kind of
force takes and queen G3 and then takes
takes Rook G8 something like this um
yeah also didn't seem too promising so
Castle is logical and after Queen B6
yeah King H1 I was thinking that Knight
D6 uh was the move I didn't see um the I
mean this uh Queen H6 move um and I was
trying to find out what was his position
after for example Knight D4 long Castle
Bishop C2 um I thought that Bishop C2
are not to take because I don't know it
same d to me to open the B7 bishop and
then there can be ideas with Rook G8 at
some point and pressure on G2 but after
Bishop C2 um black will play something
like Rook E8
anyway and yeah I wasn't sure how to
evaluate this type of position but yeah
Queen H6 is probably very precise um I
have to come back to G1 and after Queen
B6 I guess if I want to play for a win I
need to play the move Rook F2 and then
we get a very similar position after
Knight D6 Knight D4 castle and then I
don't know if takes or or Bishop C2
immediately something like this and Rook
E8 again I wasn't sure how to evaluate
and it looked double edged to me um he
seemed very well prepared I already
spent some time and um decided to to
play solid yeah to uh go for a door in
fact he he he I think he he can even
play on after Queen H6 King E1 for
example Knight D6 but then Knight D4
yeah again we get same type of thing but
with the queen on H6 he can try to go
like Rook G8 and and um I will play A4 I
mean h yeah it could be really sharp it
looks that black I mean white should be
doing well here but uh yeah I wasn't
sure I mean this is maybe also possible
so yeah he was well prepared what can I
say yeah yeah absolutely and uh Fab was
also here and he told me that the
position is very sharp and very unclear
and he was definitely worried how the
things will go so what do you think
about the tournament situation now we
know that he also made a draw you have
the same amount of points tomorrow is
the last round yeah well no in general
um I'm happy to to to to be in in this
position and to be able to fight for a
first place of course the last round
will be crucial um um are you you
playing with Leon I'm playing yeah
against Leon uh but uh yeah it's uh of
course tough game but uh it's normal in
this tournament so yeah I'll try to play
well uh I think in a way it's also nice
to have some time because the tournament
it's already advanced and uh it takes a
lot of energy so for me it's good to
have a kind of half of a rest day so you
can prepare yeah you can rest a bit and
and prepare but yeah uh overall I think
it's it's been a it's been a great event
for me yeah that's great thank you so
much l all the best of luck tomorrow and
we are going back to the studio thank
you Anastasia and we're joined in the
studio by